hi guys this is rahul from simply learn
and today we'll be talking about one of
the fastest growing and second largest
cloud computing platform in the market
right now i'm talking about microsoft
azure now before we begin let's talk
about what we'll be covering in this
video first we'll talk about why you
should be interested in cloud computing
what exactly is cloud computing what is
microsoft is your some of its services
and the uses of azure now let's start
with why you should be interested in
cloud computing now let's say you have
an idea for a revolutionary application
an idea that ticks both the boxes when
it comes to good applications one it has
great user experience and two it will be
highly profitable now for it to be
successful you'll have to release it on
the internet people need to use it they
need to spread the word and then it'll
become truly famous however for that
you're going to need servers storage
developers a dedicated network and
application security to ensure your
application works the way it does now
these are a lot of components and that's
where the problem lies there are two
major disadvantages to this approach the
initial setup is very expensive and
risky which means this requires a huge
amount of capital up front to ensure
that it works properly and the downside
is if your application does not become
famous or it doesn't return as much as
you expect it to you're probably not
going to get the money back which means
it provides a huge amount of risk and
then on the flip side if it does become
famous your number of users have
increased which means that you'll have
to buy more servers and storage systems
to keep up with your demand and this
problem can be solved with the help of
cloud computing now that you know why
you should be interested in cloud
computing let's go into the details of
what exactly is cloud computing now
cloud computing is basically a platform
that gives you access to a number of
computing resources and this is possible
with the help of the internet now as a
user all you need to do is go to a cloud
service provider through your laptop or
your computer through the internet of
course connect to that cloud service
provider and then there you go you have
access to computing the sources
now computing resources may include you
know serverless computing virtual
machines storage and so much more now
let's dig a little deeper now basically
these cloud service providers actually
have massive data centers now in these
data centers what you have are hundreds
of servers also included are storage
systems and mainly several organizations
critical components so these are very
secure safe locations where a large
amount of data is stored hence the name
data centers now it is to these data
centers that users actually connect to
collect their data or use it so actually
users can access any service based on
their requirement now like i told you
there's a number of services the user
can use for example now if you want a
notification every time someone sends
you a message or perhaps once you get an
email you need a copy of it created now
for all of this there are services and
most importantly almost every cloud
service provider has this option where
users only pay for the service that they
use so there's no charge up front where
they tell you that you need to pay x
amount of money so that you can use our
services you're only paying for the
amount of time that you're using these
services now cloud computing is used for
a wide variety of reasons firstly
there's machine learning and data
analysis now basically there are
services that analyze your data and tell
you how you can work with this data
better then there's data storage and
backup streaming media content for
example did you know that the shows that
you watch on netflix actually all of
them are in the cloud so you're
connected to the internet and you browse
through netflix and you get access to
the videos these are possible with the
help of cloud service providers this
creating and testing applications
automating software delivery which is a
component in devops and hosting blogs
and applications so now what is azure
what's the big cloud service provider
all about so azir is a cloud computing
platform provided by microsoft now it's
basically an online portal through which
you can access and manage resources and
services now resources and services are
nothing but you know you can store your
data and you can transform the data
using services that microsoft provides
again all you need is the internet and
being able to connect to the azure
portal then you get access to all of the
resources and their services in case you
want to know more about how it's
different from its rival which is aws i
suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch the aws versus your
video so that you can clearly tell how
both these cloud service providers are
different from each other now here are
some things that you need to know about
azure it was launched in february 1st
2010 which is significantly later than
when aws was launched it's free to start
and has a pay-per-use model which means
like i said before you need to pay for
the services you use through azure and
one of the most important selling points
is that eighty percent of fortune 500
companies use azure services which means
that most of the bigger companies of the
world actually recommend using azure and
then azir supports a wide variety of
programming languages the c-sharp
node.js java and so much more another
very important selling point of azure is
the amount of data centers it has across
the world now it's important for a cloud
service provider to have many data
centers around the world because it
means that they can provide their
services to a wider audience now azure
has 42 which is more than any cloud
service provider has at the moment it
expects to have 12 more in a period of
time which brings its total number of
regions it covers to 54. now let's talk
about azure services now azure services
have 18 categories and more than 200
services so we clearly can't go through
all of them it has services that cover
compute and machine learning integration
management tools identity devops web and
so much more you're going to have a hard
time trying to find a domain that azure
doesn't cover and if it doesn't cover it
now you can be certain they're working
on it as we speak so first let's start
with the compute services first virtual
machine with this service what you're
getting to do is to create a virtual
machine of linux or windows operating
system it's easily configurable you can
add ram you can decrease ram you can add
storage remove it all of it is possible
in a match of seconds now let's talk
about the second service cloud service
now with this you can create a
application within the cloud and all of
the work after you deploy it deploying
the application that is is taken care of
by azure which includes you know
provisioning the application load
balancing ensuring that the application
is in good health and all of the other
things are handled by azure next up
let's talk about service fabric now with
service fabric the process of developing
a micro service is greatly simplified so
you might be wondering what exactly is a
micro service now a micro service is
basically an application that consists
of smaller applications coupled together
next up functions now with functions you
can create applications in any
programming language that you want
another very important part is that you
don't have to worry about any hardware
components you don't have to worry what
ram you require or how much storage you
require all of that is taken care of by
azure all you need is to provide the
code to azure and it will execute it and
you don't have to worry about anything
else now let's talk about some
networking services first up we have
azure cdn or the content delivery
network now the azure cdn service is
basically for delivering web content to
users now this content is of high
bandwidth and can be transferred or can
be delivered to any person across the
world now these are actually a network
of servers that are placed in strategic
positions across the world so that the
customers can obtain this data as fast
as possible next up we have express
route now with this you can actually
connect your on-premise network onto the
microsoft cloud or any of the services
that you want through a private
connection so the only communication
that happens is between your on-premise
network and the service that you want
then you have virtual network now with
virtual network you can have any of the
azure services communicate with each
other in a secure manner in a private
manner next we have azure dns so azure
dns is a hosting service which allows
you to host their dns or domain name
system domains in azure so you can host
your application using azure dns now for
the storage services first up we have
disk storage with this storage you are
given a cost effective option of
choosing hdd or solid state drives to go
along with your virtual machines based
on your requirements then you have blob
storage now this is actually optimized
to ensure that they can store massive
amounts of unstructured data which can
include text data or even binary data
next you have file storage which is a
managed file storage and can be
accessible via the smb protocol or the
server message block protocol and
finally you have queue storage now with
queue storage you can provide durable
message queuing for an extremely large
workload and the most important part is
that this can be accessed from anywhere
in the world now let's talk about how
azure can be used firstly for
application development it could be any
application mostly web applications then
you can test the application see how
well it works you can host the
application on the internet you can
create virtual machines like i mentioned
before with the service you can create
these virtual machines of any size or
ram that you want you can integrate in
sync features you can collect and store
matrices for example how the data works
how the current data is how you can
improve upon it all of that is possible
with these services and your virtual
hard drives which is an extension of the
virtual machines where these services
are able to provide you a large amount
of storage where data can be stored now
let's have a look at what we've learned
so far in this video we spoke about why
you should be interested in cloud
computing what exactly is cloud
computing what is azure some of the
services that azure provides and how you
can use azure and with that we've
reached the end of another video i hope
you guys found this informative and
helpful thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here